that's the school but it's not the
school nurse okay my kids lunches don't
need to be this elaborate but I want to
post him on Instagram on days my kid has
been especially trying I've told him
it's his bedtime in our report actually
is taking away my child's I've had his
punishment
actually just punishes me I don't mind
going to school events but I dread
having to make small talk with other
parents if you give my kid aloud an
annoying present on his birthday I'll be
sure to return the favor on your kid's
birthday no I don't want to play frozen
with you not at all
sometimes when Caillou is on the TV I
can't help but fantasize about throwing
him up a cliff when I say I left the
gift at home what I mean is I really
forgot to get one when I said we
couldn't find a babysitter what I meant
was I don't want to go my wife doesn't
understand how her kids go through so
many fruit snacks but what she doesn't
know is I've got to pack if they have it
I told my daughter there that kid from
the park was the way but I actually just
couldn't spend one more playdate with
his mom when I put my name down to
volunteer I'm actually hoping you don't
ever call me
[Music]